so now we are going to look at the
second most popular choice by the white
namely Knight captures E5
and here if you look at the database
black has exclusively tried the move
either Bishop to D6 and D captures E4
well I think both the lines have their
individual problem
and because most of the books and videos
has considered this move
I am going to suggest in this video
something very special and new and trust
me you can get many white players off
guard from this line
not to mention it has also some cool
tricks included
are you ready look at this
Queen to E7
and the funny part is you know I have
gone through many books and videos and
very few of them has considered this
move
because it has been played very rare
but nevertheless it contains a lot of
venom
for example if white move the knight
from here then is asking for the trouble
one high profile trick exists if your
opponent continue with Knight to G4
as black get instantly winning position
with the following sequence
Queen catches e-fold double attack if
Knight go to E3 then D4 NAB the piece so
that's not a good choice and accordingly
the only reply here is Bishop to E2 but
after this very simple chance
Bishop captures G4
what can play the move F3 but look at
this bishop takes Pawn takes
Queen check and after King to F1 not
only black come up with a clear Pawn
Advantage but white king is clearly
misplaced
which all together already giving black
a huge winning advantage
thank you
[Music]
well the same goes if he continue with
Knight to F3 because after Pawn takes E4
Knight to D4 and queen to E5
we enter to The Familiar trappy
territory which we have seen earlier
for example Knight to B3
black continue with Knight to C6 and
after Knight to C3 Knight to F6 and
Bishop to E2
if you remember yup we gone through this
position we stopped white to Castle by
playing Bishop to D6
and if white play here D4 which is by
far the most popular choice
then after Pawn takes Queen takes
and the Moon Knight to B4
this is one of the Trap which frequently
occurred and where black get instantly
winning position
there is a double attack and after Queen
to Devon the star move Bishop to F5
finish off the white
and if you think that Knight to D4
resolve all white problem then you are
absolutely wrong because black has this
cute tactic
Queen catches D4 winning the whole piece
in the view of
Queen takes Queen Knight to C2 check
King to Devon and Knight captures D4
where the dust is clear and black emerge
with a piece and upon advantage
so it is pretty clear that if white
moves the knot then he is asking for the
trouble so by far the most popular
choice is D4
and after this probably the most
powerful trick in this line start with
app six
and I can't believe how many people has
fallen for this as if you look at the
database here
Queen to H5 check happen in more than
7000 games can you believe it it's a big
time blunder
why what's wrong with this well the
answer is very simple you play G6
and S why two pieces are hanging white
has to capture on G6
thinking that I am going to get a
discover check
but just one move
Queen captures E4 shutter all White's
dream as after Bishop to E2 and the move
Queen captures G6
just at seventh move of the game black
obtained the whole piece
so this is one of the high profile trick
exist in this line which you definitely
want to watch out in your own games
so it is pretty clear that after F6
white has to move the Knight
and accordingly there are three night
locations
so let's look at clockwise each of this
move
number one Knight to G4
so white is planning to play Knight to
E3 and defend his position
but against this black get instant
equalizer for example you can take the
Knight here and after Queen takes you
take on e4 where everything get
exchanged and as a highlighted over here
black has a very simple plan he wants to
bolster this Pawn with F5 followed up
with a quick long side Castle
whereupon all this position always
slightly favored the black camp
I can show you a sample line here
Bishop to Seafood
Knight to C6
C3 now you Castle
and after the move Bishop to F4
you can get the bishop Pair by playing
Bishop to D6
after Bishop to G3
you cannot play F5 right now so first
black and park the king in the corner
and after castle and the mufai
as I have shown by the arrows black has
a very simple plan he wants to play
Knight to F6 and then start marching
this kingside Pawn which already give
him a slightly better position
so this is how you should respond if
your opponent continue with Knight to G4
well most likely you are going to see
either the Moon Knight to F3 or Knight
to D3 and against each of them our plan
of campaign is very effective and also
quite aggressive on the king side
for example after Knight to F3 you can
take on e4 and after Knight to D2
I propose this very simple but effective
plan of campaign that is you play the
move F5 followed up with Knight to F6
and then you take out the queen side PCS
and Castle long
whereupon you get a tremendous attack on
the white king
and don't forget in all of this position
because of the space gained in the
center always provide him the fun
position
let me show you how practically we can
put up this plan in the practice
one of my recent game against a
candidate master
is a great example how great black
attack is in this long way
here I start with F5
and my opponent continue with Bishop to
C4 so he's clearly planning to Castle
kingside
whereupon after Knight we have six he
indeed achieved it
now comes the second important phase yup
we want to take out the queen side
pieces
so that we can now Castle long and
become the hell loose on the white cave
okay Rook to even happen I Castle on the
Quinn side and if F3 then E3 is a very
strong reply so in the game obvious
enough comes on my king with B4
and at first sight it looks scary
because white attack is coming very fast
but now comes the third and the most
important part of this line
remember this Golden Moon Knight to G4
which gives black a tailor-made attack
on the white cake
the point is if white foolishly continue
here with B5 then we can play Queen to
H4 attacking two spawns and if you think
that well not an issue what can take
this night
as there is no mate threatening but see
yourself
first queen check
came to F1 and now simple move Bishop
capture C6
and even though black is a piece down
white is completely busted from this
position
for example one of the recent game from
the database continued with Bishop to E3
white is really struggling to find a
good move here
but just one move E3
and I think white can hardly survive
from this
Bishop takes half it happened
whereupon
black deliver this killer mating
sequence
if you want you can pause the video and
find it by yourself I am showing you
right now Queen captures G2
King to E2
Queen captures F2 King to D3 and now
this nice Moon Bishop to E4
whereupon after Knight takes and the
Moon Knight to D4 wipe King actually get
checkmated at the center of the ball
well most likely When You Reach this
position
majority of your opponent are going to
continue with H3 kicking this Knight
immediately but this is where the fun
part begins as we are going to sacrifice
our night with this nice move
H5
let's go for the kill
now obviously enough white cannot touch
this Knight as after Pawn takes G4
we are opening up the H file and if you
think that G3 stop the queen intrusion
then think again has after G5
that Queen is indeed landing on the H
far
so nope taking that Knight is a risky
business for white
and accordingly white should continue
with his own attack starting with E4
but see yourself whose attack is slow
now as black comes in with Queen to H4
well credit to my opponent he tried to
defend accurately with Queen to E2
but unfortunately for him
black position is so strong that he can
continue with some natural attacking
moves Bishop to D6
if B5 then the Knight can moves anywhere
so in the game my opponent come up with
the move Knight to have fun
trying to hold on to his position
but
just one move F4
hahaha
and what can see what is coming up
well he tried Queen captures E4
but after the following sequence Queen
captures F2 check
King to H1 and now the star move
F3
and in fact
this move was so strong that my opponent
has to resign the game
the reason is very obvious the mate has
been threatened and if you try to
protect the mate by taking the spawn
then after just one move Rook to E8 and
white position is completely collapsing
so remember this nice Knight to G4 move
which gives you a very good fast attack
on the white king
in this line
well more or less same story goes if
your opponent continue with Knight to D3
as first we can hit the Deep Pawn with
Knight to C6
taking away the Square from the beaver
Knight and now take on e4 whereupon
after Knight to F4 and the move F5
yup same old story we want to play
Knight to F6 Bishop to D7 and quickly
cast along where we can generate some
King side activity
if Knight to D5 here then Queen to D7 is
a very strong reply and I have attached
a sample line in the PGN
but as per the database by far the most
popular choice is Bishop to C4 which I
am afraid allow us what we want to do
yup Knight to F6 Castle
Bishop to D7
Rook to even
Queen side castling and after B4
this time around yup indeed you can
continue with Knight to G4 but there is
a stronger move here based on the
position of White Knight
and I think you already guessed it
yup G5 attacking the Knight to H5 and
now this nice move Bishop to E8
Force his right hand he has to take on
F6 and after Queen takes
afo and H5
yes indeed we have a double s position
but the question is who is better and
fast and the obvious answer is black
as you can see white has yet to develop
his army and black has some nice fast
Pawn roller coming up including Knight
to E5 which all together gives him a
better Advantage as confirmed by modern
chess engine
so I think in the tournament practice
with some careful preparation
you can certainly create a winning
attack from this position
last but not least I think the most
critical response against our line is
Knight to C3
which I doubt any of your opponent will
find it
if they have seen this position first
time as this involves a peace sacrifice
which we should certainly take it
and after night to defy pay special
attention to this line guys because
black has to know some very accurate
stuff
here the force response is Queen to F7
after that white continue with his
onslaught Bishop to C4 so now the threat
is Knight to B6 so once again we are
forced to play Bishop to E6
whereupon white Reveals His nasty Trump
he wants to give this check
black has to take it and now Bishop
takes E6
and if you carefully look at this
position white octane three Pawn for a
piece and he has a monster Bishop
sitting
right into the black girls and at first
sight this looks so scary and in fact as
per the feeder database there are some
nice wins by the White
but I'm afraid none of the black has
played the accurate response
maturity of the games continue with
ecapts D4 and Knight to F6 which I'm
afraid not a good choice
so instead of this I am going to propose
this nice move
Knight to C6
whereupon I think the resulting
positions are quite good for the black
for example what can already go wrong if
we continue with D5 as after Knight to
default we are attacking two locations
so that
C3 Knight captures E6 getting rid of
that problematic piece and after Pawn
takes and queen to D6
if the queen exchange then E6 spawn
always remain a weak spot and black and
vegan age and whenever this happened
white only get two points for a piece
which is not going to be enough
so D5 is a huge mistake by the white
here
so the accurate response is C3 Defending
Your Center
and now you indeed goes for this sharp
position
Pawn takes D4 C captures D4
and queen to D6 pressurizing the D Pawn
well now white has to give up the bishop
and the Baseline suggested by the
engineers Bishop captures G8 Rook
captures G8
Bishop to E3
Queen to B for check
Queen to D2 and long Castle whereupon
yes indeed white get the three Pawn but
after the queen exchange the extra piece
does matter a lot
in case you are wondering why not to
play D5 here as I want to keep my lovely
Bishop right
and yup there are few games in the
database reached to this position
where I think with the accurate play
Black is completely winning
how let's find it out
first you give this queen check
attacking double spot Bishop to D2
now you take on e4 with the check
if Queen to E2
then this is the easiest one you
exchange the queen and then give this
check
whereupon black is completely winning
so the accurate response here is Bishop
to E3
but this allow black to complete his
peace development with Bishop to B4
check King to F1 and Knight to F6
dust is clear and now white has only two
Pawn for a piece
and the following Grandmaster game gives
you how quickly a black get an upper
hand
white continue with A3
Bishop to D6 has been played
and after Queen to E2
black find the elegant way to remove
that dangerous Bishop by playing Knight
to d8
Queen to B5 happened King to E7
Rook to even
but I think this gives enough time to
provide the defense by playing Knight
captures E6 Pawn takes E6
and now nice move
Rook to E8
Bishop takes A7 but I think this was a
losing mistake as after Queen to C6
what is forced to exchange the queen
whereupon black emerge with a clear
piece advantage
which he indeed converted into the
little end game
so even though this piece sacrifice
lines starting with Knight to C3
contains some Venom I think as I have
shown here black is well placed by
capturing this piece and provide the
accurate winning defense
that's it guys after watching this video
now you are confident enough to meet the
Moon Knight captures E5
remember rather than going into the main
line we are going to surprise wide with
this rare but tricky move Queen to E7
and after D4 and F6
it doesn't matter however white plays as
I have shown in this video
in most of the lines white will really
struggle as black is the one who is
better prepared
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe and comment and I
will see you in my next episode very
soon
bye and take care